this is the ethiopian grand renaissance
dam
or gert for short erected on the river
nile's main tributary
the blue nile it took almost a decade to
build
and it's meant to be part of ethiopia's
transformation
roughly 65 of the country is not
connected to the power grid
energy from the dam could more than
double ethiopia's current output
fulfilling its needs and making it an
exporter
but the dam is also highly controversial
due to its location
the nile's main source the blue nile
starts in ethiopia
at lake tana
the river flows towards sudan and joins
the river's other tributary
at sudan's capital khartoum before
heading downstream to egypt
gerd is being built here on the border
with sudan
near the blue nile source
the dam will catch water in its massive
reservoir
whose surface area is larger than that
of greater london
this will inevitably have an effect on
how much water flows to downstream
countries egypt
and sudan egypt is home
to almost 100 million people who depend
on the nile
for 90 of their fresh water supply
some fear that ethiopia will leave too
much water in its reservoirs
during periods of drought endangering
the flow downstream
that could leave egypt's farmers unable
to irrigate their lands
causing major food losses
and all this as the effects of a warming
climate
have already strained egyptian
agriculture
the effects for sudan seem mixed
one fear here is that the gerd could
jeopardize the operations of sudan's own
dams on the nile
however sedan also sees an opportunity
to get cheap energy from ethiopia thanks
to gerd
and it could regulate water flows that
have sometimes caused
flooding these competing interests are
among the reasons why negotiations over
the dam's operations have been difficult
no comprehensive final deal has been
reached
but even with an agreement cooperation
between egypt
ethiopia and sudan will be needed for
the years to come
there are more projects planned along
the nile
and the effects of climate change and
growing populations
mean water could be an increasingly
scarce resource
for more let's bring in aya ibrahim who
filed that report and has reported from
the region
quite a bit for a dw news ayah welcome
so clearly negotiations are difficult
but what are the main sticking points
i mean right now the main sticking point
is uh
egypt and sudan's attachment to whatever
agreement comes out of these
negotiations being a legally binding
agreement
this has been very important for these
two parties throughout the negotiations
but now ethiopia is hinting that maybe
this they can discuss these
these matters but the legally but the
legal binding aspect of the
of the deal is suddenly now coming into
question and this is very important for
egypt and sudan
uh not because of the initial stages of
the filling which have
which has already been completed but
their big thing is what happens if
there's a drought
what if there's a prolonged period of
drought and they want ethiopia to be
legally attached to releasing a certain
amount of water from their massive
reservoir
to offset the drought periods but
there's also competing
economic interest we're talking about
three countries and they have their own
individual interests is that all there
is to it or is there something else
also afoot i tend to think that the
competing economic interests are perhaps
the easiest part to understand of this
conflict the
more difficult part to understand and
the less tangible is that this is also
about history and this is
about identity this is about who gets to
set the rules about
a very very important asset for all
aspects of life
i mean you have ethiopia which sees
egypt egypt's
claims to the nile as colonial heritage
that they completely reject
and you have egypt who thinks who's you
know the nile is
interwoven in egyptian identity and in
egyptian history
and it's hard to think of egypt without
denial at least to the egyptians there
has been talk of war
is there any risk of armed conflict over
this disagreement
it's possible but unlikely and it's
possible only because
leaders of both egypt and ethiopia have
not ruled it out completely
but if you look at the current situation
the fact that egypt's parliament just
last week
gave essentially a green light for egypt
to intervene in libya
egypt now militarily at least has too
much on its plate
and if they were to strike the dam it
can always be rebuilt again and there's
also the geopolitical aspect which is
that sudan is right in the middle
so unlikely but possible it remains to
be seen you never know
hi ibrahim thank you so much for coming
in
for more let's bring in william davison
he's a senior analyst for ethiopia with
the
international crisis group he joins us
now from addis ababa
uh mr davidson what is the main sticking
point
at the moment
um well there isn't one sticking point
but there is a sort of whole
category of legal issues um which are
proving
um hard to overcome and they're also
related to outstanding
disagreements over some hydrological
issues
and to give an idea of what i'm
referring to there um as mentioned in
your report
um there is the debate over how to
manage droughts how the renaissance dam
will operate in the event of a drought
so how much water
will be released from the gerd's
reservoir during certain categories of
drought
and then there are a number of legal
disputes notably
on the issue of arbitration so if there
is a future dispute
will there be third-party arbitration to
resolve it
ethiopia rejects that that egypt and
sudan insist on it
and then a major issue which really
connects to all the others
is if there are any future developments
upstream
of the gerd on the blue nile how will
that be factored into any gerd agreement
um because it will impact the amount of
water flowing into the gerd
and therefore there might be a need to
adjust the agreement but the parties
simply do not agree
about how to factor that in to the
agreement at the moment
considering uh these sticking points
which country needs to be more flexible
out of the three i mean considering that
this dam has been built
on the ethiopian side of the border is
it ethiopia
that needs to be a little more flexible
i think everyone needs to be a little
bit more flexible here just make
whatever concessions they find
acceptable and
will help to get to an agreement there's
some quite tricky
disputes this issue of arbitration that
i mentioned that's a kind of binary
disagreement so it looks like maybe by
improving a third party mediation
process and other trust building
mechanisms
maybe the focus can be taken off that
dispute over arbitration
with regards to drought management
ethiopia has said that it wants sudan
and egypt
to also use their reservoirs to combat
drought
so you know our sudan and egypt prepared
to do that can ethiopia come up some
proposals
for how that will work and maybe also
egypt could
soften some of its demands about the
amount of water it wants ethiopia to
release from the gerd reservoir during
times of drought
ultimately everyone has to play their
part on this
william davidson from the international
crisis group thank you so much for
breaking that down for us
thank you